Dove the soap company has just partnered
with a young activist this young
activist's name is Ziana Bryant and if
you've heard that name before you might
vaguely remember this person it's
because she made a little bit of a name
for herself by ruining a young white
student's life over a misheard remark at
some BLM protest in 2020. so there was
some mostly mostly peaceful extremely
fiery BLM protest and this gal Ziana
Bryant who is Black said that she heard
this this young woman uh
say that the protesters would make a
good effing speed bumps
that never happened there were
investigations into this there was Zero
evidence there is significant evidence
that this Ziana Brian just completely
made it up there was no evidence that
this young gal this UVA student Morgan
benninger ever said anything even like
that
but it didn't matter
because
the damage was done falsehood flies
while the truth is getting out of bed
so over a year years of this young gal's
life were ruined by this cynical
activist Diana Bryant who was lying and
now she's got a new object of her
activism it's no longer BLM and mostly
peaceful riots and looting and burning
the country down now she is a fat phobia
activist and she's being rewarded for
that with presumably a bunch of money
and fame by Dove
my belief is that we should be centering
the voices and experiences of the most
marginalized people and communities at
all times so when I think about what
that Liberation looks like to me it
looks like centering the voices and the
experiences of those who live in and who
maneuver through spaces and institutions
in a fat body it looks like making
accessible spaces and having
conversations that are aware of the fact
that people have different bodies and
that they are interacting with space and
people and institutions and communities
in a different way fat Liberation looks
like fully embracing those differences
and having those conversations instead
of shying away from them to learn more
about that Liberation and the campaign
for size Freedom that Dove is supporting
visit dove.com forward slash size
Freedom tap in join the campaign support
the campaign this is important and we
should all be talking about it
okay I'm not gonna make fun of fat
Liberation and I'm not gonna make fun of
even Dove so much here I want to focus
on something
one word that that woman said
and she said it multiple times
conversation
this is what liberalism does for
liberalism the highest point of politics
is not doing anything
it's not changing anything it's not
achieving a concrete objective
it's just having endless conversations
when you hear a political figure say we
need a conversation we need a national
conversation on Race we need a
conversation on our democracy I think
it's time that we just it's so important
that we have conversations about the
ability to have conversations while
conversing about the significance of
conversations
that's
what politics is all about when you hear
that kind of talk you know that you are
one hearing from a liberal and two being
deceived you're hearing from someone who
wittingly or unwillingly is is deceiving
you because endless conversations
don't do anything in politics and in
politics things have to get done
decisions have to be made policies have
to be implemented people have to get in
line
but that is contrary to the open
free-floating conversational language of
liberalism man and so what happens in
practice is that the Liberals who
ostensibly want to de-politicize
everything stop coming to firm rigid
conclusions just kind of keep the
conversation open man what they end up
doing is they end up partnering with
people who are decidedly illiberal to
usually secretly Implement their agenda
this is why the Liberals always go soft
on antifa antifa doesn't want to have
conversations when antifa shows up to
your event they're not there to talk
okay they're there to crack some skulls
and throw explosives at the venue and
kill people if they can
BLM doesn't want to talk BLM doesn't
want to have conversations BLM wants to
steal the microphone shout their
propaganda
then cut the mic and start looting
stores and shaking down businesses and
seizing power and oh also killing people
that's that's what those groups want to
do
and the Liberals can pay lip service to
how this has gone too far and we don't
like that we don't we would never do
this
but they fund those groups they bail
those groups out of jail when when the
BLM rioters finally did get arrested on
occasion Kamala Harris bailed them out
of jail she didn't bail out the peaceful
protesters she bailed out the rioters
who committed crimes Joe Biden's staff
did the same thing they raised money to
bail these criminals out of prison
because the illiberal forces the hard
leftists and antifa and BLM
and outright Communists and outright
anarchists they do the dirty work for
the Liberals and the Liberals get to
pretend that they're above politics no
no we don't we don't under we don't we
don't view Politics as a distinction
between friends and enemies we don't
want to force anybody to go along with
our program we just want to be open and
conversational
but if you don't go along with our
program antifa is going to show up at
your door oh but they're not us no they
were totally different
but hey antifa when you do show up and
crack some skulls you're not going to be
punished for it that that is
such a deception
even the very fact that liberalism says
we just have the economic sphere we just
have the social sphere we have the Civil
Society that's not political that's not
politics and electoral offices and laws
and no it's just the free market and the
free conversation and then meanwhile
what Dove Partners up with these radical
activists who who are not there to talk
to you do not beware beware the endless
conversation
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles you
know a company is looking at for you
when they upgrade your service and don't
charge you for it this is great news for
new and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but haven't made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 55 zero percent more
5G data plus their new mobile hotspot
this is why I love Pure Talk they're
veteran owned they only hire the best
customer service team it's located right
here in the USA that alone is worth
switching over most families are saving
almost a thousand dollars a year while
enjoying the most Dependable 5G Network
in America remember you vote with how
you spend your money so stop supporting
woke wireless companies that don't
support you when you go to puretalk.com
Knowles you will save an additional
fifty five zero percent off your first
month because they value you go to
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
buy Americans for Americans
hi Mr Knowles this is Abby a from the
chat my question for you is in regards
to college because I'm homeschooled I
have a really big jumpstart on my school
this will be considered my senior year
of high school and next year I will be
eligible to start dual enrollment once
my two years are up I have it planned
out that I will have accumulated around
60 college credits if I were to continue
on the next two years I would have a
bachelor's degree in finance shortly
after I turn 19. my question is is it
worth spending the time and money to
complete my degree if all I want to do
is be a stay-at-home mom and raise a
family my dad says I have to have a
backup plan in case something happens to
my husband and I need to have a way to
support my family I can't wait to hear
your thoughts love the show and keep up
the good work
I generally discount discourage people
who are not sold on going to college
from going to college
I am not one of these conservatives many
conservatives will say oh don't go to
college at all it's totally bunked no if
you are drawn to go to college and you
want to go for the right reasons I
encourage that I'm certainly not one of
these conservatives who says if you do
go to college you should major in some
practical degree like a stem or
something parts of stem like engineering
or some I totally disagree with that the
point of University education is to get
a liberal education it's not to do job
training you can do job training
whenever later on down the line the
point of a university education is to do
things that are completely not practical
at all to just cultivate your rational
will and to read Dusty old books that
will help you to see the world more
clearly
um in your case
you're saying you would want to get this
degree for a practical purpose you're
not particularly drawn to it
but because of the way your schooling
has already worked you would you would
essentially get a college degree in one
year
I I don't know are you engaged to be
married right now
if you are engaged to be married and
your husband is I know he's in the Navy
or something and you're gonna get
married and then he's going to deploy
and you're going to move all over the
country and it would make going to
college very very difficult then maybe
okay maybe you get married and start
having kids whatever if you're not
engaged to be married though if you
don't have the prospect of this wedding
anytime soon and
and you've just got a year where you
don't know exactly what you're going to
do with it
I don't see why not I don't I don't
think it's bad to have a backup plan uh
I wouldn't I wouldn't put off the life
that you want to live
for this life that liberal modernity
pushes you into or so that you have a
plan B but it doesn't sound like you
would be pushing off that life
some people do some people push it off
four years of college then maybe a
couple years have been of a higher
degree or even a PhD and then a long
time of a career and then they don't
even start thinking about settling down
until they're 30. that's not the
situation you're in
so practically
I don't know if you're not doing
anything else with the year might as
well pick up a finance degree boy what a
great clip that was now make sure
that you subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time